[ __ ] is the oldest resident of one of
the UK's smallest zoos a territorial
animal blissfully unaware of the
fragility of his situation Cedars Nature
Center is home to 25 different species
built for the local community it is a
labor of love but not being a charity
it's fallen through the cracks when it
comes to financial aid from the
government with no visitors income has
disappeared but the cost of keeping the
animals remains the same with no funds
to fall back on they are relying on
donations
if they can't reopen by the summer the
future is bleak we've only got a couple
of species here which other sensors
would want but we're in exactly the same
boat there's plenty of other small
species zoos everyone would be in a
position where they're trying to offload
their animals and find new homes for
them apart from our armadillos and ours
Arella none of the big centers will want
our animals and will have no other
option that have to be euthanized the
more established and higher profile zoos
have a stronger chance of staying afloat
but the pressure is still immense zoos
like Marvel are frantically fundraising
securing bank loans and furloughing
staff to try and see them through the
crisis and while the government Support
Package is welcome it is limited in
scope negotiating on behalf of the
sector is the British and Irish
Association of zoos and aquariums we've
been working with the government Support
Scheme but we don't think it's going to
be enough for all and especially for the
long term we think it may be enough to
just get past the crisis but zoos as a
sector will need long-term investment
but there are also thousands of zoos
around the world that can't rely on
donations of government help Uganda
wildlife education centre is home to 280
animals right now there's orphaned
elephants biggest problem is loneliness
but soon it may be food when we closed
the implication was that no coin was
coming him as we speak right now because
mana was coming in through gate
collections
accomodation restaurant specialized
programs those are not happening anymore
even if the lockdown and soon tourism
will take time to recover in the
meantime the virtual tours are springing
up and online donation pages hoping to
secure enough support until gates can
reopen charlie angela al jazeera
hampshire